‏right
are people that are in the hell fire for
eternity
has
this
not of the people who pray
‏and we
those who played
كفر
[Silence]
‏and
মুসলিম
قر
از
[Silence]
س
much
‏more
of
would
failingay
will by to by fail
because are
اصول
النووي يقول النووي رحمه الله تعالى
والراجح من اقوال الاصوليين
ان ما يحرم على المسلم يحرم على الكافر
وان
الكفار
مخاطبون
بفروع الاسلام كما انهم مخاطبون
باصوله
او كما قال رحمه الله
اصول
‏of
and her
is that the disbel is just as
intr and isl as the is and what is upon
thel is upon the nonml andit
uponl
[Silence]
‏after that
some food is permed
to nonl of not
‏are
[Silence]
والتقوى ولا تعاونوا على الاثم والعدوان
حم
حمl
upl
however
when
the nonml we don't
teaching themلام
توحيد لا اله الا الله محمد رسول
‏here
to
the prayers missbel
for that they fail to
holdable
time was
مع الخائضين
اذا عندنا هنا انهم ما بينهم وبين الله
الصلاه
ايه لم يف يفوا بها
وما بينهم وبين الناس
لم يوفوا بما امر الله من الزكاه ولم نك
نطعم المسكين
و
ما كان من شاني
ما كان من شان الاسراف في الزمن والوقت
واللغو كانوا يخوضون مع الخائضين
وما كان من ناحيه الايمان والايمانيات
فكانوا يكذبون بيوم الدين
هذه احوالهم
اللهم
‏here
number we not of those pr number and
those need number and we used to
waste time with those
‏number
قوله ولم نك نطعم المسكين اصل هذه الكلمه
ولم نكن نطعم المسكين لكن جاء هنا حذف
النون
تخفيفا ولم نك نطعم المسكين
لو جاءت ولم نكن نطعم المسكين
هل في فرق في المعنى؟ ما في فرق هذا الفرق
فرق لفظي
يعني لم نكن
ولم نك وانما الموضوع من باب التخفيف يقول
نطعم المسكين
المسكين
في لغه العرب من السكون سكون والسكون عدم
الحركه
يقال للفقير
وللعائل مسكينا
كان الفقر اسكنه فلم يستطع السفر لم يستطع
الحركه كما يتحرك بحريه اصحاب الاموال فهو
مسكين اي اسكنه
وحجم
فعمله
الفقر
والعاله والاحتياج
مسكين in
personير
sometimes together and are two words
that the schar mention that if they
mentioned together they have separate
meanings and if they mention separately
they have the same meaning
ان شاء الله تعالى
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمني وكرمه وجوده
ان ينفعنا وان يبارك لنا جميعا في كتابه
والقران العظيم اساله تعالى ان ينفعني
واياكم بما فيه من الايات والذكر الحكيم
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد